so happy for rumor willis when she took
home that mirror ball trophy now that
was just a few weeks ago and this
weekend she's on the move with some of
the dancing with the stars crew now
they're headed out on a tour called the
perfect 10 tour and we were with the
gang because they got prepped
hey you guys i'm here in atlantic city
and we are about to have dress rehearsal
for the perfect ten tour and i could not
be more excited to be here
rumor will be dancing at 25 tour stops
which surprised even her partner val
rumor will be a huge part of the tour
i thought she was gonna do a couple of
shows here and there but she's actually
signing up for a majority of the tour
i love it because it's keeping that part
of my brain working and keeping you know
and i almost have more time now to take
you know the tiny details of the routine
say that i've done before and really
finesse them we found out rumor is even
going to travel on the dancing tour bus
12 dances one tour bus yeah that's a
riot what happens on the bus stays on
the bus it's definitely a bit more
relaxed because you obviously have
longer than three days to work out a
whole dance i'm totally impressed that
this dance troupe can learn an entire
show in just a few weeks and it all
kicks off in atlantic city tomorrow
night we pretty much go straight from
the season to rehearsals and we kind of
ride that energy ride that wave of a
very successful 20th season so this tour
hits 40 cities through the summer the
last performance is august 11th in
illinois so get your ticket